we had your neighborhood co-stars Max
Greenfield and Beth Bears here and there
was a little bit of a debate about
something so do you mind taking a look
at something for me sure okay let's take
a quick look at the tape
I just feel like who do you think the
best dancer is on set if we're going to
have to be honest about this guy who did
you say play feel like it's me
why are you laughing
no no
I think it goes Cedric I actually have
never seen Tashina dance
me Tashina would say it's me 100 well so
I'm gonna go Cedric and then I'm gonna
say me and then I'm gonna say that
I love it yes
Beth 100 was like obviously me she's so
confident yeah she has the one move
though it's just gonna be she's gonna
twerk it's the one it's a twerk and it's
not a very great twerk
I was like she's very thin so this might
be an interesting sport making the study
would be like girl come on now
who gets your vote out of Max or or best
oh Max Max okay Max is smooth man you
know yeah well I'm the denitario of uh
it's for the that's for the older people
the older people
no but I you know I definitely you know
I definitely have the dance moves you
know 17 years on Soul Train uh you know
Dances
I did not dance I know but that's so
cool I grew up watching Soul Train I
loved it so much I did I loved it
the big leg kicks you know crazy stuff
yeah but it was cool somehow you were
just like yeah I could do that but you
can't even do that in a club right now I
just would imagine going out and just do
a big leg kick out of it oh my God
I haven't been to a club in a while
because I'm like a single mom but like
I'm like I feel like when I went to
clubs too it was just guys just do one
move and it's just like inappropriate
like I didn't come here for that I
didn't come here for you to just be like
yeah yeah like yeah
I'm like why are you why are you behind
me right now sir like I didn't it's
weird but I didn't know about you Kelly
I'm just saying don't do that to people
you're turning her off that's like the
best way to turn that off
blank all right face her sir anyway our
next I'm gonna have to text my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
y'all have a great night